Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 168th
Episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Good morning!
This is FUWAMOCO Morning, Ruffians!
Nice to see you!
Miss you!
BAU BAU!
Good morning!
I'm nice and refreshed and ready for a new week, Ruffians!
Maybe there's a lot of Ruffians who are confused.
There's nothing confusing about it!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
But those who are joining us for the first time today!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week.
Yeah!
And there's a good reason for that.
So that we can get a bit more balanced.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you on the wrong timeline?
No you're not because you're awake, bright, and early for a new day, a new week, and a new month because you know now it's August.
What?
August is a fun month.
There's lots of fun things going on.
Moco-chan you big August hater.
Ruffians, are you August haters too?
Ruffian what?
What?
That's it, the voice is speaking?
FUWAMOCO-chan, you know, August is here and that means there's a lot of fun things happening, right?
Ruffians, have you been having a lot of fun together with us?
Maybe, you know, you've been a little bit busy with this and that, work, school, you know?
Maybe even going bowling or something cool, right?
Bowling's pretty cool too.
I don't know which is better.
Let's take a look at what's been going on, Moco-chan!
This is not better than... Moco-chan, why are you kind of hesitating like that?
It's not better than bowling.
Did something happen?
Or boarding.
What is it then?
If it's not bowling, it's not boarding.
Similar.
Similar to bowling.
You could probably try bowling, but...
Another Pero Sighting.
A Pero Sighting?
What?
How is a Pero Sighting similar to Bowling or Bowling?
Bowling, you know, Pero is round.
It's good, but it's kind of weak.
I don't, I, maybe not to me.
Okay, well, let's take a look at my Pero Sighting, Dad.
Let's take a look.
Dad.
Dad!
Oh!
This is a happy scene, but... What?
We look closely at Pero there.
He doesn't really look as nasty as usual.
Oh, you're right.
He kinda looks a little proud.
Yeah, he sort of has like a warm aura around him.
Yeah, he's kinda strange.
You know, love fans.
Sneaky.
And looking a bit huggable.
Maybe, you know, maybe somehow he can feel all the love and the passion that the love fans have for us.
I need him a little fluffier.
A little bit nasty just for this small moment in time.
A little less nasty, yeah.
I need something nasty, are you sure?
Are you sure?
I don't know, he looks really proud and like, oh yeah, Ruffians.
Okay, you're okay.
No!
Maybe that's the way to make Pero... In front of this beautiful, beautiful flower stand.
Maybe you can make him not so nasty like this, huh?
Passion?
Maybe.
Maybe that's the way to stop Pero Ruffians.
Huh?
Wow!
Thank you for the start of the world tour!
I'm Ruffian!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your messages!
Of course, for stans, Itabags, cute cosplayers, and your big BAU BAUs.
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
I feel happy now.
That's kind of a rare feeling, huh?
Not so nasty, Pero Sighting?
No, you know, because I can feel the Ruffians' love.
BAU BAU!
But we're gonna quick quick quick quick change.
Here is your Ruffians.
I don't wanna have to say this Moco-chan.
Ruffians.
We have an apology to make.
It's a pretty serious one.
I think some of you maybe know of it.
A big mistake occurred.
That has occurred on our own channel of all places.
Last week, Cecilia and Gigi.
They ended up taking over FUWAMOCO Morning!
I know, Ruffians!
What the heck!
They made a CCGG Morning!
I'm so sorry, Ruffians.
You know, we were sad and disgusted.
Traumatized even.
It was scary.
Yeah.
You didn't notice a difference.
We did, but the damage was already done.
Uh-huh.
I get blind.
Well, we understand, you know.
There were a lot of strange things discussed.
Do you think they were censored properly?
I don't know.
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm waiting.
I'm waiting!
I'm Mococo!
She is Mococo!
And together we are FUWAMOCO!
You know it's right!
Don't be sad, okay?
Don't be sad.
I'm so in love with you!
You know, I promise you, from here on out, that nobody other than FUWAMOCO will be here doing FUWAMOCO Morning.
Yes.
No guests.
Nothing.
No.
Nobody.
Just FUWAMOCO.
No surprises.
Got that?
Yeah?
Yeah, that would be best, right?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita
Um, maybe an apology.
An apology about the entirety of a certain collab string that happened with La+-senpai and Nerissa.
That's all we'll say.
A certain off collab.
Certain events transpired.
We were there to help do the collabs, translators, and moral support.
Because you know, Nerissa, she's still doing her best to learn Japanese.
And I think we were terrific moral support.
I won't apologize for that.
But then something suddenly changed and we became involved in it because Lapu-senpai, she needed a break.
A break?
I think she needed to catch her breath a bit.
But, we must say, it was educational for those involved.
Yeah, lots of Japanese learning!
And, FUWAMOCO, we have something to confess too, right Moco-chan?
Confession.
You want a confession?
Don't be scared.
Wow!
Nerissa!
She did not hit us once.
No.
She wouldn't!
No!
Yeah.
So, instead she hit herself.
And she was all sorts of red afterwards.
Yeah.
No way!
She won it.
No.
What?
La+-senpai on the other hand, she begged for her to be actually hit, so... I guess she got what she wanted.
La+-senpai on the other hand, not so much.
Yeah.
She got what she wanted.
And I guess we all kind of did end up...
Huh?
Yeah.
And you know, a lot of Japanese was taught with... I guess some English too.
Yeah, you know.
Rappoi-senpai, she knew some of the words Nerissa was saying and we asked her right away.
Yeah.
I'm surprised.
And we also wrote up this script here.
You know, with Rappoi-senpai about...
30 minutes beforehand.
Yeah, we just wanted her to be happy as well, you know, as all the other hololive listeners as well.
It was a very nice bonding experience that transcends languages and cultures.
Ruppoi-senpai, how about this?
That's great.
Write that one down.
That's very gross.
Ruppoi-senpai, what about this one?
Yeah, but, you know, all the staff and staff and manager, they said it was great!
Yeah!
But, the pleasant part, she did seem to run home pretty fast after.
Maybe she was a bit embarrassed?
Maybe?
We hope everyone enjoyed it and had a silly time with us!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
We just celebrated our second anniversary!
De-den!
We had a very special Seki Anniversary celebration stream!
We did it in 3D full body!
In a brand new 3D self booth!
It was so much fun!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Put our paws on things like this.
In case you didn't know, Ruffians, it's different than, you know, the regular studio technology.
This is a different technology.
Different.
The 3D self-studio.
Yeah.
So, we're really, really happy.
It's a place, you know, it's still being worked on further.
But we hope we can have more silly 3D streams together in the future.
We're really impressed.
Yeah, with the 3D for body tracking and everything.
That pose Yamako-chan is extra silly.
I was testing it.
It's new technology, you have to test it.
But it was really fun.
And we also announced something that we were working hard on for a long time and very excited to share with you.
I'm very glad FUWAMOCO produced second anniversary celebration merchandise!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO Evening shirt.
We're very picky about the design.
This would be beautifully paired together with a happy puppy.
Happy too!
We're gonna jump out of the shirt!
BAU BAU!
And next we have the Pero on the Brain Cap.
I think this one we're most excited to see you wearing, Ruffians!
We already tried it on.
Moco-chan looks super adorable in it.
It was really nice and soft and not hot at all.
Not at all.
It was really light.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
And we have the FUWAMOCO donut question!
It's in the shape of my favorite donut, a pon-dori!
And so one side is Fuwawa and one side is Mococo!
So it does kind of mean that you can't see us both at the same time.
But they are a bit on the big side because I thought that was
You know, that way you can hug them, you can sleep.
Or you can put them on your sofa too.
It's the perfect size.
Do not sit on us.
Oh no, Ruffians are gonna sit on us now, Moco-chan.
Don't.
BAU BAU!
And... We have a voice bug!
This one's a very special situation.
Can't cafe deal with FUWAMOCO.
So yeah.
We kind of go a little crazy when it comes to cats.
Please stick it out here!
It's in English and Japanese too!
There it is!
And we have the Fufufu Adventure Mat here.
This is the first time we've ever had like a big, beautiful design of Icomochi-mama that's a desk mat!
And it also works for TCG as well!
Yeah, so please stick it out!
Icomochi-mama's love.
Mocomoco-chan, you hugging me like that is surprising me.
BAU BAU!
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
If you wanna know where you can get your paws on them, you can get them on the official hololive shop in the link below!
They're on pre-order right now!
Up until, I think, the beginning of September!
So please get your paws on them now, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
But that is not it for our Advent celebration!
No, no, no, no, no!
We also had!
We released a brand new song!
Lifetime Showtime!
It's a very, very precious song to us.
You might remember Ruffians.
We actually shared it with you for the first time on the very day we debuted two years ago.
The song is an introduction song written by Suo Patra.
Patra-oneechan.
She's a very talented Vtuber.
Very ASMR goddess.
She's really talented at making music.
She loves retro games.
She's very cute.
But this song, it introduces you to exactly who we are, you know, because we are twins.
But we are a little bit different.
I love FUWAMOCO-chan's fuzzy.
Yes!
Introduce both of us!
And finally we're able to share the full version of Lifetime Showtime with you!
This time with this beautiful animated music video!
Thank you so much!
Thank you United and Miu for making something
Ruffians are tiny.
What are you talking about?
We're not gonna step on you.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Please go and check it out there!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for 100,000 views!
Over 100,000 views on Lifetime Showtime 2!
We hope that, you know, it can continue to be a song that we treasure for years and years to come from now on!
You know, maybe even a lifetime!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
But that's not it for the anniversary celebration stuff, huh?
We still haven't quite celebrated in other ways, right?
Yeah, we still have Advent 2nd Anniversary!
Well, tonight at 6-7pm ET, Ruffians, we're gonna be having a very special off-collab together with all of us!
We're gonna be doing some karaoke together!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Happy 2nd Anniversary!
Speaking of you know our 2nd anniversary celebration.
There was also a special episode released.
3D animation series Holo no Graffiti over on the official hololive channel!
Have you seen it?
Abyss!
Did you see it?
Check it out!
You saw it!
I saw it yesterday!
BAU BAU!
It was cute!
I liked it when you know she already used the bookmarks like kunai!
Oh yeah!
We get into all sorts of trouble and a lot of things happen.
You know, I always say things like, can you stand up for me?
Why?
And what was it?
Don't sit down?
Yeah.
Girls don't sit down?
Bad girls don't sit down?
Yeah.
Was that it?
You'll have to check it out and find the context on this, you know?
What does that even mean?
They're making us say silly things, FUWAMOCO-chan.
BAU BAU!
Thank you.
Thank you so much Ruffians and Adventrix for all your love and support and BAU BAUs together.
Thank you for everything these past two years.
FUWAMOCO will continue to protect this world no matter what!
BAU BAU!
BAU
Are you sure about that though?
I'm not breaking, you know.
Pokey's dead!
Why?
Ah!
Different.
Yeah.
Pokiboo.
No windows.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO!
ASMR.
Yes!
Our very first ASMR stream!
What?
We did it together.
ASMR!
ASMR what did I say?
ASMR.
Oh.
ASMR stream we did it together with the Doggy Pack members!
It was a test.
A test, you know.
I feel like, judging from the Doggy Pack's reaction, it was a successful first test.
But we were super duper nervous and, you know, we prepared a bunch.
A lot of testing, a lot of trial and error.
Just to be able to kind of get it to the best sound it could be with our noobiness.
Yeah.
Thank you, Ruffians!
There are mistakes.
Incidents.
We'll continue to try our best.
No incidents with the Ruffians is broke, I don't think.
No!
So vague.
Right?
Yeah, but we'll ask our senpai for help too.
Maybe get some lessons from them if we're so lucky.
You know, maybe that way we can continue to try our best to help you relax.
I feel like, you know, relaxation is also a very important part of being able to protect the Ruffian smiles too.
It's pretty rare for two twin demon guard dogs to do ASMR together, right?
It'll be something nice that we can, you know, explore more.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your super sweet comments and encouragement, too!
Yeah, we know we still have a long way to go, but we'll do our best, okay?
BAU BAU!
Please check it out!
Support of the Doggy Pack are interesting!
I know!
I love to do lessons and all!
Senpai!
Okayu Senpai!
Katsurane-chan too!
Thank you Abyss!
Well, there is another very exciting thing that happened!
You were there!
Right, Ruffians?
Hololive English -Justice-'s Elizabeth and Gigi both made their 3D debuts last weekend!
Oh my congratulations!
What did you think, Ruffians?
Were you blown away?
Did you boink boink?
I felt like Gigi's... Whoa.
Wizard Ojii-chan!
Yeah!
That was so haza!
It's a bit chaotic.
You like Ojii-chan?
Wizard Ojii-chan?
I feel like, I don't know if everybody noticed, but that was Gigi's 3D debut.
That was Wizard Ojii-chan, which could also be Gigi.
Gigi.
Yeah.
You know... Did you realize it's Gigi and... There's two Gigi's.
And Gigi's 3D debut.
Lots of debuts.
Oh gosh, yeah.
But at FUWAMOCO, actually, you know, we had something funny happen.
We walked by the green room at the studio while Gigi was doing her high-souls for her 3D debut.
We saw a green room for Furukawa-san.
Yeah, and I was like, I'm seeing Furukawa-san, and we're like... We were really surprised when Gigi said, oh that's the wizard!
The wizard here!
Yeah!
I have a wizard!
Wizard Ojii-chan!
Now we understand.
I don't understand the right words.
But now, it's yes.
Information is processed.
And the kids quieted too!
It was amazing!
Gigi was singing the song for us, you know?
Gigi's the best.
Gigi is great.
Yeah, we love it so hard.
But we're really glad that they both got to do the 3D debut of their dreams.
And you know, that's not it.
There's still two members of Justice Riot.
Cecilia and Raora.
They're gonna be making their 3D debuts.
And she's going to be debuting on the 8th at 5pm.
Don't laugh, Ruffians, okay?
What did you say, Su-su-su?
Su-su-su, yes.
No.
No, no!
She's going to begin her DD debut on the 9th at 5pm!
So please don't miss it!
Put it into your calendars, okay?
There is also the Justice 3D collab next weekend, okay?
I feel like that is easy to maybe miss, so don't forget it.
Don't miss it.
You'll be crying if you miss it, okay?
We don't want that.
Yeah.
Well, you know, especially after just how amazing Elizabeth and Gigi's were too.
Please go and cheer them on!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I'm so happy and all.
I feel like I'm a big senpai or something.
Thank you.
I was like, oh, what if there's more kouhai that join us?
Then we'll have kouhai and our kouhai will be senpai and then oh no!
Then it's been a while, then, huh, Moco-chan?
We can't howl that.
That would be frightening.
Maybe that's how Calli-senpai feels, huh?
BAU BAU!
It's dusty!
Dusty like us!
No!
We'll be a fuzzy here.
There's, you know, second anniversary things.
Yeah.
Ruffians!
Are you excited for August to start?
Are you like, Moco-chan is like, August, August.
Yeah.
Are you looking forward to it?
Do you need maybe a little bit of a push?
Really?
Moco-chan, what do you mean?
Are you protesting this?
You really need it.
It's a big month for you, Sima.
Moco-chan!
It's your birthday month!
Why are you so excited?
Hi.
FUWAMOCO-chan, maybe you have something that you could say that would help her cry just a little bit.
Okay.
Oh boy!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
It's time to wake up!
And go out for the day!
Are you ready to face it?
Huh?
No.
You're still waking up.
You don't want to.
Really?
Really really?
Are you sure?
Well then.
I guess it's okay just this once, okay?
You can go back to sleep.
Okay.
Okay, I'll tuck you back into bed.
But get a good pineapple, okay?
I know you'll be able to take one the day after.
We're always on your side!
Got it?
BAU BAU!
Ganbatte desh!
Moco-chan, the Ruffians gonna be able to fall back just for 10 minutes after this.
Just a little bit.
I don't want to use the ASMR skill.
Ruffians probably can't even hear the howl.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at the Doggie of the Day.
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
Today we have... Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Max!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Mind you, Garibaldi, no, this is Max!
This is Max!
And he look, look at Max's little bowtie there!
Yeah!
Very, very cute!
It's supposed to be cute!
But yeah, he looks very good in that.
Very great.
Very grandiose.
But yeah, FUWAMOCO-chan, how does Max BAU BAU?
Hmm... Huh?
Huh?
BAU BAU.
FUWAMOCO.
Other than that, I guess, Max has some really great hobbies.
You know, things like sleeping, and eating, and asking for food.
Very refined hobbies.
It sounds like a good schedule, right?
Yeah, how do you help me?
I think, you know, Max, sometimes it might be hard, a little bit hard for him to see clearly sometimes.
Oh, maybe because there's a window in front?
Ah, well, you know, but we hope that Max finds his way into some excellent cuddles!
Yaaay!
BAU BAU!
And next we have our next playmate.
Today I went on a walk!
De-den!
What a beautiful beach!
So picturesque!
A beach?
Seaside?
What's the difference between a beach and a seaside?
I don't know, is this a place to ask?
It's a beautiful place!
It looks like, you know, when somebody tells you to draw a picture of a beach.
Or like a sea.
I don't know.
You draw like the water, and then like a bench maybe, and a tree?
I don't know, this looks like a photograph.
Ruffians is FUWAMOCO.
This is a picture of a beach.
Beaches have sand or rocks.
They have benches and trees, okay?
It's very nice and relaxing.
And it's a good way to get a refresher.
Beautiful beach.
Yeah, so I'm really really glad that you got a bit of a change of pace here.
Spend some time outside.
It's a lake!
It's a beach!
Apparently it's a lake, okay.
This is a beach!
Ruffians, whenever you're having a rough time, we hope that you'll go on walks like this too.
Think of this beach here.
Okay.
Dry, okay?
Think of the sound of the leaves and the dolphins.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
BAU BAU!
We know FUWAMOCO likes picking up cicada shells, and has even eaten inago, which is their food.
Are there any insects you're afraid of?
Like spiders or gokiburi?
Yeah, we even got to pick up a bunch of cicada shells!
I'm super happy!
We got five for Advent!
We were going on a walk so then we were looking around for them.
We were looking for anything shiny around our feet.
And then we found like a...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
That was beautiful!
A whole cicada, yes!
Yeah, we kicked them out!
I don't know if it's helping.
And you know... It was so beautiful, it was our perfect specimen!
And then you know, we saw it.
Actually... We ran into Nene-senpai!
At the studio!
And then you know, we go, Nene-senpai, look!
Look, a present for you!
And she's like, kawaii!
Cute!
She was so happy!
I've never seen this!
Nerissa always runs away when I let Nerissa look at them.
Really, Nerissa, guess what I have in my bag right now.
Huh?
Yeah, but, uh... Once we're free, though... When does the kira flies at us?
It's mainly flying bugs, you know.
Yeah.
Cicadas.
We were looking for cicadas, but then we saw gokiburi instead.
Yeah.
That wasn't really... It's only scary when you're not expecting it.
It's in places like, you know, your home.
Yeah, home.
That doesn't happen for FUWAMOCO, though.
But spiders are also unsettling.
I don't really like them.
I know they're friends, but they're kind of... Mama Puppy deals with the spiders.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Please remember, we're always waiting!
For, you know, your doggy of the days, your questions, your vlogs, your Pero sightings, please send them to us with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
We're waiting!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream, we have De-den!
On Nerissa's channel, we're having a very special 2nd anniversary celebration of Club Karaoke with all of our fans!
And a big announcement.
Look at this beautiful picture here though.
It's such a nice piece of carpet.
What could it be?
We'll have to see!
It's at 7pm PT tonight, so please be there, okay?
BAU BAU!
And well, FUWAMOCO, I think we have a new schedule coming up with us, so be prepared.
So we hope you'll look forward to it.
We'll share it with you over on Twitter and also on YouTube on the community tab here.
As soon as we can, yeah.
So please look out for that, okay FUWAMOCOs?
For Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCOWORD is... BAU BAU August!
BAU BAU!
You did it again, huh?
You did it again, huh, Moco-chan?
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Dark Blue Wing!
BAU BAU!
Dark Seers!
Liz Kang!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Anon.
BAU BAU!
Unicake.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!